I'm Dana Britt.
I'm Jennifer Wang.
I'm Laura Parody.
And I'm Dalia Abbas.
And we're Kid Collab!
Have you been part
of a group project
where you felt like
your printers were
doing all the work?
Maybe you felt like you
were doing all of the work?
Well, so have we.
I'm sick of doing all of
the group work by myself.
I'm tired of always having to
delegate every single task when
it comes to group work.
I'm tired, as a teacher, of
having to collect 1,000 papers
and not knowing which things
came from which student
and who did all of the work.
My teammates and I,
we created Kid Collab
to help kids practice the
21st century skills that are
necessary in today's society.
When each kid gets
their own information
that they have to
learn to contribute,
they have something unique
to share with their group.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All students play
a valuable role
in being a part of the activity.
So for my activity,
I was the historian.
I really felt like I was
valued as a team player.
And I love Kid Collab
because it merges adventure
with problem-solving.
Nobody felt awkward stepping
into a leadership role.
And the structure was
really clearly defined.
It provided an authentic context
for collaborative learning
for students to come
together and to solve
a modern-day problem
using evidence.
Hi, I'm Sarah, and I've
been a teacher for 10 years.
So it was really interesting
doing this activity,
seeing technology
for our group work.
And one of the things
I found with group work
is that kids often
sit back and let
other people do all the work,
whereas for this, there's
not that possibility.
Everyone has their
own role, and they
get to explore different
elements of those roles
as well.
I thought Kid Collab did a
really good job of making sure
that all of that logistical
stuff got taken care of,
but making sure that people
had substantive things
to do as well.
We've created Kid
Collab so that students
will have the
opportunity to in-person
have a virtual
collaboration experience.
And there are few
products out there
that are able to provide that.
We don't think we have
all the answers to how
to facilitate
effective group work,
but we do think we're
onto something when
we highlight what
it is that could
make group work more effective.
[MUSIC PLAYING]